the japanese
manga series attack on titan has
captivated our imaginations and greatest
fears
for those of you who are new to the show
well it involves
terrifying humanoid giants with an
insatiable appetite
for humans beware of potential spoilers
and nightmares to come
so if titans were real and
suddenly appeared around the world could
we survive
or would we all be breakfast
what is our greatest defense against
titans
what kind of technology could we use
against them
and how could we take down a colossal
titan this is what if
and here's what would happen if titans
were real the acclaimed series
attack on titan is set two thousand
years in the future
it focuses on the last civilization of
humans
who live in a city barricaded by three
50-meter walls the citizens of this
protected city lived in peace for a
whole century
then one fateful day a colossal titan
reached the wall that opened a pathway
for
all sorts of creepy smaller titans
these man-eating giants range in size
and
shape from 4 to 17 meters
but the colossal titan is much taller
at a towering 60 meters and
they all seem to be nudists for whatever
reason
would somebody get these guys a nice
suit or something
unfortunately these aren't friendly
giants
by any means it seems that their
sole purpose is to gorge on a buffet of
humans
so what sort of tech could we use
to defend ourselves in the show
the nation's military uses
omnidirectional mobility gear
grappling hooks used to swing around
quickly and
scale great heights to deal deadly blows
to the titans
looks like fun to me while automated
grappling hooks
might work well in the show we would
likely have to attack and maneuver
around the titans by
other means helicopters drones or
even wing suits come to mind but
why is it essential to attack from the
air
well titans are strong fast and
some of them can even regenerate when
wounded
but they do have one weakness
the nape of their necks the trick is
getting up there but couldn't we just
nuke them all and be done with whoa
now don't press that red button just yet
nuking them might do more damage than
good
we'd have to deal with the toxic
radioactive fallout
and would have to spend years rebuilding
communities
we might have a better shot taking them
down by aiming at their necks
from afar with a sniper rifle
but with some titans moving at
incredible speeds
this could prove pretty difficult having
the foresight to
evacuate before a disaster is usually
your best bet at survival
for most school children in the united
states following the protocols for
an active shooter could save lives this
involves hiding locking or barricading
any doors
silencing phones and staying low
and quiet while this might work in the
short term
titans are known to smash through
buildings with ease
so you might want to increase your home
insurance premiums
ahead of time if you live in the city
you should try to head deep underground
you could take refuge in a subway
station like
washington heights which lies 55 meters
below new york
or if you've got 15 million dollars
lying around
maybe you could buy a subterranean
bunker
like this one in kansas it's 15 stories
deep
and can hold 75 people for a maximum
of five years if all else fails
we could call for an aerial attack from
the military
using drones or fighter jets but
just when you think you've got them
suddenly
a colossal titan appears these titans
are
much larger and release explosive energy
and heat when they form
destroying and killing anything within
the blast radius
and to top it off they emit steam
as hot as lava at around 602 degrees
so you'll need a protective suit if
you're getting close to these behemoths
these colossal titans are also known as
titan shifters they are humans that have
transformed into ugly steamy
muscly giants the only way to kill this
braid of titan
is to pull the human host out of their
necks
which is easier said than done
if we can't take them all down from the
air
or with snipers we could try to block
the sun
temporarily titans get all their energy
from
sunlight this could kill two birds with
one stone and
slow down global warming too if
this tires them out enough then maybe we
could strap them down with ropes and
attack them more effectively while
we might stand a chance with this
strategy
what if other giant creatures showed up
out of the blue
we would stand a chance against godzilla
well that's a story for another
what if
you